hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast multi-dimensional
high-throughput imaging with the new
image Express micro confocal system I am
Judy O'Rourke of levers and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by rag routes comm
the leading social media site for
science professionals and sponsored by
molecular devices lecturer devices is
one of the world's leading providers of
high-performance bioanalytical
measurement systems software and
consumables for advancing protein and
cell biology with over 130,000 placement
and laboratories worldwide their
instruments of catalyzed brilliant
scientific research described in over
80,000 peer-reviewed publications before
we start there are a few instructions we
want to hear from you during this
interactive broadcast so please ask
questions or leave us a comment answers
welcome to you can do this by hitting
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window and typing in
your comments and questions we try to
get to as many as we can and we'll
follow up if we don't have time today
want a better look you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you can't hear or
see this presentation properly let us
know by clicking on the support button
on the top right or use the Q&A button
we'll make sure we try to resolve any
issues now let's get right to today's
presenters we are proud to welcome Jane
hesley and gracious handy Jane hesley is
an application scientist for cellular
imaging at molecular devices she has
more than six years experience
developing cell based applications using
image Express high content imaging
systems and meta express analysis
software most recently her focus has
been on utilizing biologically relevant
cell models for toxicity studies she has
a BS in animal science and ms in biology
Grisha shammy PhD is the senior product
manager for cellular imaging of
molecular devices which is scientist
background is in cell biology physiology
and biophysics he has used and developed
imaging techniques and technologies
throughout his career gursha has endless
molecular devices for over ten years
driving launches of several image
express systems and med express software
and most recently the launch of the
image Express micro confocal system I
will now turn it over to Jane thank you
and welcome to our webinar my name is
Jane hesley and I'm an imaging
application scientist at molecular
devices in this webinar I will cover
some confocal applications specifically
3d spheroid screening and no wash
homogeneous assays next grissett Randy
the product manager for imaging will
introduce you to the features of our new
image Express micro confocal imager
first in case you're not completely
familiar with high content and
high-throughput imaging I'll spend a
minute giving an overview of the
workflow and the potential applications
traditionally biologists would treat
some cells with drugs or growth factors
and put them on a microscope slide after
staining them or in some way marking
their response with fluorescent proteins
or they may be looking at morphological
changes with transmitted light now
instead of peering at them through the
eyepiece they take pictures or images to
study and get a sense of whether or not
the cells reacted to the drug even if
the acquisition with a conventional
confocal microscope is automated the
hands-on time can be multiple hours and
the skills to run a successful
experiment may be high under the ? are
the possibilities of what happens next
because it's not common anymore that the
images are simply judged by the
researchers experienced I by using a
high-throughput imaging system
experiments can be just as easily run on
anything from microscope slides to 1536
well plates with no compromise in image
quality the image Express micro system
can be set up in a few minutes and the
biologists can walk away while images
are acquired and even
immediately for analysis by the
integrated software once numbers are
generated for the parameters of interest
responsive cells or wells can be
identified statistically analyzed
plotted and conclusions drawn since all
images and measurements are stored
together in a database the burden of
keeping the data organized is removed
from the scientist and the results can
be shared within a networked company or
organization the hands-on time is
dramatically shortened due to the
automated and seamless integration of
acquisition analysis and viewing of
results briefly there are hundreds of
applications that can be done with
automated imaging obviously these slides
lists just a subset of them in these
images you see example of cocultured
liver and fibroblast cells a high
magnification image that could be used
to analyze multiple subcellular
structures and an example of
angiogenesis in a gel matrix this slide
shows more examples including sample
images of neurite outgrowth a 3d
spheroid and transgenic zebrafish a nice
example of small organism imaging is
this Drosophila larvae on the left is a
video made from time-lapse acquisition
at low magnification and the right
illustrates how come focal acquisition
of individual Z planes allows you to
completely separate and visualize
individual structures within the
Drosophila larvas head
why use 3d models cell models for assays
are becoming more complex in order to
better mimic the in vivo environment and
provide greater productivity for
compound efficacy and toxicity screening
naturally there's an increasing interest
in using three-dimensional assays for
modeling cancer and tissue biology these
three-dimensional in vitro models may
span the gap between two dimensional
cell cultures and whole animal systems
and can provide unique perspectives on
the behavior of stem cells developing
tissues and organs and tumors while the
overall goal of using 3d models is to
improve productivity the purpose of this
first study was to optimize cell culture
and develop new imaging and analysis
methods that can be used for compound
screening through assessment of multiple
phenotypes in human cancer 3d models
specifically we optimize the workflow
for spheroid formation staining an image
acquisition 496 and 3d for well assay
formats for three commonly used cell
lines hct116 du145 and hep g2 we have
developed multi-parameter assays and
analysis methods for spheroid cultures
that provide subcellular resolution and
characterization of single cell and
overall spheroid phenotypes there are
some challenges associated with
efficiently capturing the structural
detail and identifying marker
localization in complex 3d models such
as spheroids whole organisms cells grown
throughout a gel matrix or in the
presence of multiple cell types which
may actually be layered upon each other
I'll focus mainly on the example of
using spheroids in a screening assay for
part 1 of this presentation then in the
second part touch upon some other
homogeneous screening assays and explain
the benefit of using confocal optics for
acquiring the images to obtain the
information needed when cells are grown
in an extracellular matrix such as
Maitre gel there's generally unavoidable
background fluorescence if not from the
gel itself then from the difficulty of
adequately washing out the fluorescent
stains used on the cells here's an
example of two images of some pc12 cells
grown throughout about an 80 micron
thick layer of Maitre gel
while acquiring the images with wide
field optics still shows nice cellular
detail the background fluorescence from
the major gel is apparent imaging the
same cells with confocal optics
illustrates the benefit of the thin
sectioning ability of the confocal
acquisition see how the background
fluorescence is eliminated which will
often make analysis easier I don't want
to give you the impression that confocal
optics are always necessary for high
content imaging for many if not most
flat 2d assays with cells in monolayers
light field imaging is the correct
option even for identifying punctate
objects within cells or making
morphological measurements wide field
imaging of a single plane is the
simplest and fastest screening mode all
the features I'm going to illustrate for
3d confocal imaging are available for
use with wide field including bright
field imaging time-lapse acquisition as
shown here sorry it was so fast and
collecting and analyzing stacks of
images in the Z plane confocal optics
will improve image quality in cases
where you need to reject fluorescent
backgrounds such as in no wash assays or
if the media is contributing
fluorescence it's also great for those
thick samples I mentioned in the
previous slide so you can adequately
resolve different layers of cells in
space this example shows our software's
3d rendering of images collected from
the bottom up through the middle of a
spheroid that was stained with live dead
markers
the other one shows an example of
stepping through the plains of cells
grown in maître gel so now we'll address
some of the technical challenges of
using cancer spheroids for high content
imaging the first one will be culturing
the spheroid you plan to use followed by
some insights into staining of these
structures next will be techniques for
imaging the stain sphaeroides and then
analyzing those images you will want to
go from reproducibly culturing spheroids
to segmentation of the images you
acquire to deciphering the data you
generate in your assay there are
numerous methods for creating spheroids
I'm using an illustration here from 3d
bio matrix of the gravity or hanging
drop method in the hanging drop method a
plate with tiny holes in the bottom in
the configuration of a microplate is
placed above a humidified chamber cells
in media are pipetted into each of the
holes and the drop containing the cells
hangs suspended by surface tension the
cells gather in the bottom of the drop
and readily aggregate into a spheroid
spheroids can be imaged right in the
drop or after forcing it into a
microplate some other ways to create
spheroids is to grow them on a scaffold
such as the one illustrated in this low
magnification image of an array of
spheroids on a special plate from toyoko
CI where they utilize techniques to
repel the cells from the areas between
the arrays and attract them to specific
areas on the plate or by using a 3d gel
matrix like maitra gel many cell types
will spontaneously form spheroids when
not confined to a microplate surface
there are some challenges for these
methods when it comes to media xchange
compound addition and possibly requiring
transfer of the spheroids to another
plate for imaging
we've been successful using ultra low
attachment plates from Corning that
allow much easier cell culture media
change and compound addition the
workflow is similar to the standard
culturing of cells using a little extra
care as if these were non adherent cells
for example we don't attempt to
completely remove media from the wells
before adding fresh here you can see the
movie of spheroid formation from hct116
colon cancer cells over a weekend imaged
at three hour intervals spheroids are
formed within 24 hours but are nice and
compact and ready to treat after two
days this is an example of a 96-well
plate of spheroids after seven days note
that every well has a single spheroid
and the size and shape are quite
consistent with diameters varying less
than ten percent the spheroid self
center and can be captured in a single
field of view with 10x or 20 x
magnification this means the instrument
doesn't have to find the spheroid in the
well or stitch multiple sites we have
overcome several challenges to make the
assay convenient and feasible for
automated hcs one of the challenges with
spheroids is the staining steps first of
all die penetration especially of
labeled antibodies may be impaired by
tightly packed cells secondly wash steps
may either move the spheroid off center
or disrupt its shape especially if it
has been weakened by the compound
treatment so for this viability assay we
used hurts for a nuclear stain to stain
the nuclei and all the cells calcein
a.m. to indicate cell viability will
stain metabolically active cells and
atheneum homodimer for dead cells it
stains the nuclei of cells with damaged
external membranes we use live cell
staining one mix containing all three
dyes and no washing before imaging we
have also successfully used caste-based
37 from edgerrin apoptosis and a couple
of different might attract or dyes to
gauge compound effect on mitochondrial
integrity
here are a couple of graphs showing our
optimized incubation time and die
concentrations we decided a two to three
hour incubation of the live spheroids at
37 degrees c gave the best intensity
signals we also generally ended up using
about a two to four times higher
concentration of the dyes than we would
normally use for our 2d cell toxicity
assays to get a representative idea of
what is occurring throughout the
spheroid we set up the image Express
micro confocal to acquire multiple Z
planes there's a finite distance a
fluorescent microscope can reliably
acquire clear images into a thick
structure due to the interference of a
large number of cell layers because of
this we generally image from the bottom
of the spheroid to just over halfway
through it to get a consistent and
reproducible sample stack the scientist
has the choice to either save each and
every one of those Z planes or else to
collapse images into a single 2d image
on the fly you can also analyze either
each Z plane or else just the 2d
projection image here's an example of
what I was just describing confocal
images of a spheroid stained with
hoechst were taken indicated distances
from the well bottom as the image plane
moves up from the well bottom toward the
spheroid center regions of distinct
nuclei appear first in the center at the
surface of the spheroid in contact with
the plate bottom then forming a ring
pattern that increases in diameter until
it reaches some maximum associated with
the outer surface of the spheroid the
maximum projection image is generated
from 11 individual images taken 20
microns apart nuclei segmentation is
shown for the corresponding 60 micron
and 160 micron images and also for the
2d maximum projection image the
individual nuclei and the masks are
given a random faults color this graph
plots nuclei accounts for a single
spheroid measured from the 11 different
Z images taken indicated distances from
the plate bottom it shows that the
largest sampled area that can be said
was found between 60 and 100 microns
deep into the spheroid the infocus
nuclei counted past 200 microns were the
one seen on the spheroid perimeter this
bottom graph was generated from the
nuclei count in the maximum projection
image from a single spheroid based on
the number of individual images in a Z
stack taken over a 200 micron distance
in other words if you took 10 z planes
to cover the 200 micron distance versus
30 z planes and built a 2d maximum
projection the nuclei account did not
get any better from these results we
decided to typically image our spheroids
using 11 z planes 20 microns apart these
two videos are to compare z stacks
acquired with the 20x objective using
either wide field mode or confocal mode
basically it is just showing you
stepping through the Z stack from the
bottom to the top of the spheroid in
this case I used an algorithm to
generate a best focus 2d projection from
those previous stacks of images as you
can see the confocal images result in
lower background fluorescence and
therefore more accurate counting of the
nuclei in several experiments we
collected both wide field and confocal
stacks of the same spheroids and
compared the nuclear counts on average
the software is able to identify about
80% as many nuclei from a wide field 2d
projection as from a confocal 2d
projection now to show the assay put to
use this is a screenshot of a spheroid
plate treated with six compounds with
increasing concentrations as you go up
the plate this was a live cell assay
stained with the mix of three dies as
described previously as you can see
different compounds cause various
phenotypic changes in spheroids from
stunted overall size and the stores
pouring treated wells to beginning to
disintegrate at the top of the
doxorubicin column
you can see several examples here that
show the mask of the object and also
masks of individual cells scored for the
presence of different markers we easily
set up a custom analysis module that
would identify and report out only the
parameters we wanted to look at we
wanted to consider a number of readouts
that characterize morphological changes
like spheroid width and area also we
evaluated total cell count in the
spheroid by Herc's stain nuclei and used
the viability markers to count the
number of live cells dead cells and
metabolically active cells while these
masks show what remain of the spheroid
based on her stain nuclei you may also
analyze the cells in the entire field of
view so that the Dead or a pop taught
excels may be accurately counted this
bar graph shows several different
measurements for six treatments compared
to the untreated control which is shown
in bright red the top graph is
illustrating the count of cell by cell
results where the bottom graph shows
data collected on the spheroids diameter
area total area of live cells and total
calcium intensity within the spheroid
another way to look at the data is shown
by the results from this 96-well plate
screen of four compounds the number of
live cells or other readouts can be used
to define IC 50 s for each compound to
wrap up this application section I hope
we've shown you some useful information
that will help you if you're interested
in compochia imaging of spheroids I
think we've shown that 3d spheroids can
be reproducibly grown compound treated
and stained then high content confocal
imaging of spheroids is suitable for
compound screening and micro well plates
that spheroid phenotypes can be
characterized using morphological
analysis and population counting and if
you want further information I encourage
you to read this paper high content
assays for characterizing the viability
morphology of 3d cancer spheroid
cultures which contains a lot of this
information and even more
now i'm going to move along to the
homogeneous antibody binding assay
commonly known as s matt i'm going to
first explain how this assay works
because it's not commonly used in all
cell-based imaging labs either cells
that express some kind of target or
beads that are coated with the target or
floating in suspension in a microwave
plate an analyte is added and in this
case we're using a species specific
antibody called human to human antibody
as the analyte as it would be if someone
wanted to test the production of a human
antibody from a hybridoma colony then a
fluorescently labeled secondary antibody
against the analyte in this case it's
goat anti-human igg labeled with an
alexa fluor is added to the mix often
these are incubated for several hours to
allow complete binding and for the cells
or beads to settle to the bottom of the
plate it looks here like the fluorescent
signal will be concentrated on to the
beads assuming there are some human
primary antibody to complete the
sandwich if you image those wells and
measure the amount of alexa fluor 48
signal associated with the beads you see
a curve generated in a dose-dependent
manner meaning as the concentration of
the analyte increases the intensity on
the bead increases but here's the
surprising part for those unfamiliar
with this no la chasse the signal of the
highest analyte concentration is
actually decreasing I'll quickly show
you why in the next slide but I want you
to know that when we are evaluating this
assay for lower detection limit we are
omitting the points that are to the
right of this peak
now the ratios aren't completely right
in this illustration but it shows you
that in the presence of a very high
analyte which is the reddish human
primary antibody all the binding sites
on the beads might be filled up with the
human antibody and all the binding sites
on the secondary can be filled up with
the human antibody as well this could
occur to the extent that there's no
sandwich formed between the capture
surface the bead and the fluorescent
detection the secondary antibody this
results in lower signal on the beads
which shows as the right side of that
previous graph it can also result in a
higher background in the media around
the beads or cells with that explained
here are some actual images taken at 10x
magnification of 6 micron beads with the
fluorescently labeled antibody sandwich
onto them while there is still in excess
of the labeled antibody in the media or
buffer since remember we don't wash it
in the antibody off the white field
image on the left and the confocal image
on the right are scaled to the same
intensity values and by drawing a line
through the images and plotting the
pixel intensity seen along this line you
can see that you get much lower
background signal if using confocal
optics as well as a much higher signal
to background ratio of the beads versus
the background you might guess that with
the improved signal to background ratio
the lower detection limit will be much
better if confocal optics are used we
often see 5 to 10 times better
sensitivity in an antibody binding assay
by using confocal images we calculate an
LDL as the lowest concentration we
tested that is 3 standard deviations
above the average background bead
intensity that's the bead in the
presence of the secondary antibody but
not the primary human antibody here we
saw a point 3 nanograms per mil with
confocal versus 4.7 nanograms per mil
with wide field as you know these
absolute sensitivities will be dependent
on each antibodies purity specificity
affinity off rate etc
these homogeneous assays can also be
done in cells this example shows cho
cells expressing an unnamed receptor and
combined with the ligand and then
detected with a flora flora labeled
antibody to the ligand these were imaged
with the 20x pineapple objective and we
see a clear benefit of confocal imaging
to segregate cell membrane staining
especially against a high background in
summary the image Express micro confocal
system provides background rejection
that is necessary to measure homogeneous
assays confocal imaging delivers lower
detection limit for antibody binding to
beads that's more than five times lower
than the corresponding wide field images
confocal imaging also enables greater
resolution of antibody binding to cell
membrane receptors I concentrated on the
applications that make use of the
confocal side of our automated imaging
system but the solution is also relevant
for your 2d wide field imaging screens
if you collect exquisitely high-quality
images and make segmentation and
analysis easy using meta Express
software and either the turnkey or
customized application modules then you
evaluate the measurements that are
output and plug them into a QT express
data analysis program for identifying
the hits or trends in your experiments I
will leave you with an eye full of
pretty images while we transition to
Grisha to tell you more about the new
image Express micro confocal system
thank you
thanks gene that was a great overview of
a couple of applications enabled by
onion product as a reminder i'm
christian d the product manager for the
high content portfolio at medical
devices i will now give you a short
introduction to the new product the
image express micro confocal system as
the reminder this the system is both a
confocal and wide field automated imager
that enables applications in the
screening research and live cell space
the movie on the left is taken over 16
hours in a 3d for wall plate with each
weld repeat repeatedly imaged
approximately every 20 minutes you will
see some cells some of those highlighted
in with the orange circles going through
cell division additionally the marker
used goes to the nucleus in a punk to
structure when the cells are going
through the s-1 phase as i mentioned we
are repeatedly visiting each well of the
3d for wall plate instead of sitting in
imaging in one well the movie
illustrates a few things one the system
is imaging in from focal mode and the
cells are happy alive and going through
their normal cell division to the system
has the stage position actually to come
back to the same area of the world
repeatedly over these 16 hours enabling
the type of long-term lifestyle assays
that are image Express customers
routinely do to do these multi-day
lifestyle experiments and track cells
over time we additionally wanted to
ensure that you had a colloquialism that
met the sensibly and throughput
requirements of the screening workflow
the image on the left is taken at 4x
magnification over three default well
you will see that in one shot you
capture the entire well of
with that single image but the two-color
a say you can acquire the whole treaty
for well in 12 minutes on the right we
have a unique feature on our image
Express systems as well as the new image
image Express micro control system and
that is at 4x in a 50 with a 1536 well
played we can capture for wells in one
shot this allows for really ultra high
throughput imaging in linda's 1506 well
format because though you're capturing
four times more wells you don't need to
capture four times more sites and you
can do that in the same 12 minutes this
will roughly translate into greater than
160,000 wells per day in a 24-7
environment automated system what you
get with the Express microcon fuckl
system as I mentioned you get both a
confocal and white fully mature the
system comes configurable with 12 100x
magnification extremely large field of
view one of the largest on the markets
at one point nine six millimeter squared
at connects that's enables you with one
shot of the 10x objective together
entire 1536 well imaged and an extremely
bright solid light engine for the
reliability and since sensitivity needs
of a consult Oracle system that is
expected to run 24 hours a day seven
days a week
access more complex biology quickly for
the system let's compare with any clear
bottom plate type 1 well to 1536 weld
round or flat bottom transfer plates and
slides note that much of the spheroid
data that Jean presented on the
application sections of this webinar
used round bottom plates that not all
hcs systems can image reliably we can do
that the system is also capable of
greater than three log dynamic range the
stage resolution is less than 100
nanometers and you saw the accuracy and
precision that allows us to return to
where those cells are dividing and the
system comes with both high-speed laser
and image autofocus not all systems on
the market have bought that capability
laser autofocus helps with the speed and
not pitching a sample and the image
autofocus is when your biology your
cells are not in a reliable place above
the well bottom and it might vary and
you might need to find that within an
image auto focus the image expressed
micro high content imaging systems are
flexible to meet your research needs
they come with a variety of options
including complete and rival control
including humidity gas and temperature
control true phase contrast transmitted
light and bright field options and
fluidics for onboard liquid handling
additionally the systems can be output
outfitted with a robotic plate handler
for those 24-7 screening requirements
as I mentioned earlier the system has a
number of objective lenses to meet your
application needs going from small
animal to subcellar resolution you can
purchase the systems with from 1x 200x
air objectives 20 to 60 X phase
objectives and 40 to 60 X oil immersion
objectives and all objectives are user
changeable the system is unique in
coming with adult optics spinning this
technology that allows you to choose the
more those right for your research agile
apt optics technology uses a bright
solid-state light engine proprietary
spinning disks with advanced optics and
optimized pinhole geometries as well as
a high sensory SC mass detector mode one
white fill imaging gives you the fastest
throughput possible mode 2 is for
confocal imaging we offer either 60
macron pinhole for basic and focal
imaging or 42 micron pinole for
high-resolution confocal imaging and
lastly we offer a high throughput
confocal imaging mode which is a unique
50 microns slit technology that enables
you to image with the speed of
whitefield
so how fast and sensitive is the system
in reality to show you that in this
webinar this is a movie taken real time
of the system taking z stacks through a
Maitre gel thick sample in three colors
Debbie fitzy and Texas red with the
overlay shown next to it as you can see
the Andes exported times in you know 100
100 100 to 200 milliseconds hundreds of
milliseconds as you can see in this conf
okle mode you can see these crisp images
coming up real-time a number of planes
in each color and being displayed live
for you essentially live for you and so
that gives you an impression of how what
the throughput would be how sensitive is
going to be for your applications so
I've totally available about the system
and Jane give you an overview of two
applications what you seeing pop up here
are a variety of other applications that
are enabled by the system the top left
here you see some knurled images that
were near ons in tissues on the right
here you'll see some cells that was z
stat chronometer gel these are nuclear
puncta these are parasites grown in a
you know multiple cell culture system
this is a brain or neural system of a
zebrafish embryo and here is a
homogeneous antibody binding to the
membrane of a cell membrane of a cell
and many of these applications can be
sped up to be done at greater than
40,000 wells a day at high resolution in
can focal mode
the image extra systems are also
controlled by medexpress software which
is an integrated image acquisition
analysis package and with medexpress 6
and 6.1 which just came out which
control both the image Express micro XLS
and the image Express micro confocal
systems you get an integrated package
for your acquisition analysis needs
built into the medic stress software
acquisition analysis interface is the
ability to acquire and analyze Z stacks
so here you're seeing the acquisition
window for a multi-well plate and you're
able to set the bottom where your focus
is the top of your Z acquisition you can
vary the number of step sizes and the
number of steps that will be due to that
Z depending on the size of your spheroid
or your major gel and here's a zoom of
that window additionally you'll be able
to select whether you only click the 2d
projection or the z-series and 2d
projection and how you're going to
project that image there four different
ways to project that Z Z image and that
is all part of the package you get when
you get em in Express six and 6 1 with
one of your image Express Microsystems
at the heart of medexpress software is
the image analysis tool box that enables
a variety of analysis routines to
address the continuum of from turnkey to
flexible routines that customers need so
on the left we're showing our
application example application module
for those routine assays like maybe cell
cycle accounting nuclei or new I doubt
group on the right we're showing our
most powerful journals or macros that
allow a wide variety of flexibility from
controlling the hardware and making
intelligent decisions based on analysis
routines and in the middle we have our
custom module custom modules will give
you the flexibility of our journals but
the turnkey once one has created a
turnkey nature of application modules
because once an application module is
generated in a custom module those can
be shared with others and reused with
very little intervention so on the
application module canned routines I'm
showing six examples cell cycle right
outgrowth all the way to cell viability
those are the raw images and these are
the segmentation and there's 19
application modules available that we
scanned routines but you can also build
your own application modules whether
it's looking for mitotic spindles and
centrosomes doing label-free cell
proliferation assays not just finding
your rights but finding puncta that are
near new rights and doing migration
assays
our solution is a complete imaging
workflow when you put stat for medical
devices starting with the image Express
systems for the acquisition the med
express for system control and setting
up your analysis routines medexpress
powerful for the ultra high throughput
analysis that you might have need for in
a screening environment acuity Express
for data mining all tied together with a
data management solution MTC store so
there's no absolute requirement for
importing and exporting data from our
solution and but you can bring
third-party data into the system as well
as automate the export of that data from
our solution so we're bringing to market
an automated system for all the imaging
needs it's fast reliable flexible cut
spectacular image quality that you'd
expect open focal system it's got the
sensitive you need complete work for
solution from image acquisition of data
mining and we've based it on the image
Express micro with more than 1,000
publications out already on the market
and the system just builds on the image
Express micro portfolio so on that note
we'd like to get your thoughts and take
questions and thank participating in our
webinar
excellent presentation thank you for
bringing that information to us during a
question-and-answer session a series of
poll questions will appear on your
screen please take a moment to
participate at this time we would like
to open up the QA Grisha had to step out
and we would like to introduce be pet
rocks the Kofi who's together with Jane
has we will answer any questions you
have dapat is the application scientist
at molecular devices and he has been
supporting the high content imaging
product portfolio for over five years
before I get started with all your
question through the quick reminder
about how to reach us today questions
can be sent via the green Q&A button the
lower left of the presentation window
will get to as many as we can our first
question is mentioned confocal could
benefit a homogeneous apoptosis assay
what do you mean okay I'll take that
mrs. Jane so for homogeneous assays
using confocal optics allows you to
reject the background and often in
apoptosis assays whether it's in 2d cell
culture or in 3d you'll have a lot of
cells that are floating away or lifting
off the bottom and by being able to do
these stacks and reject the background
it allows you to get a better count of
the cells that have been marked with the
a pop tonic marker as well as any other
dead cells that are not really attached
to the cell bottom the well bottom what
other types of cells have you tried to
form 0 you're right okay and I'll take
that one also we haven't done an
exhaustive list but pretty much every
cell we've put into the bottom of these
low attachment round bottom plates have
forms farads sometimes a little bit of
what i want to say some protein will
help them to form form steroids but i
would say in addition to the cells i
already talked about we've done u2os
cells and we've had success with them
induced pluripotent stem cell-derived
cardiomyocytes how long can you keep
self alive for live cell assays alright
we in house I showed you a video of
growing spheroids over a weekend so that
was about two days and eight hours I
think and then we've also had customers
they do who successfully done their
assays in image Express micro confocal
for up to seven days can you describe
some of the automation options available
I'm vpad answer that one molecular
devices offers several different robotic
arms and collaborates with several
different vendors so we have for robotic
integration your best solution will
probably be to contact your local sales
representative and application
scientists for any additional
information basically any systems that
are currently integrated or had been
integrated with image Express micro
previous versions xls the XL or the
standard will also be compatible with
the images for us microcut fogel thanks
about the objective is 100 times oil
immersion available I'll answered that
one as well too so the platform is
compatible with a wide range of Nikon
objectives and we do offer some oil
immersion objectives all at the hundred
axes available as well 60 and 100 thanks
is the mega express software compatible
with any other platform we are able to
the software is able to import and
analyze any type of tiff format or image
via most image formats we also have a
couple of solutions for being able to
integrate the image formats from
different vendors such as you know from
different microscope platforms into
medics
in an automated way through our NBC
store database if that's desired and
about how long did it take to complete a
confocal V stack of a single steroid
using 1120 um
I'm sorry did we repeat that question
sure about how long does it take to
complete a confocal V stack on a single
steroid using 1120 um step okay that
would depend on the exposure time you
need for the dye that you're trying to
measure but generally stepping through
maybe a second or maybe a second or so
ever or less for one steroid for a per
well for each per wavelength for example
the nuclear scenes i was showing right
um could the image express be sterilized
for example with peroxide
we do have some customers that have you
know put our systems into greater than B
sl1 or BSL to and the decontamination
procedures are pretty standard I don't
know about peroxide in particular but
we've you know typically use bleach or
you know seventy percent ethanol I so
you know mixture which was more time
what guide you to show HP cells in
division okay I don't think in my
experiments I didn't specifically show S
phase although if you're well if you're
talking about the video that was shown
in grisha's where he was showing cell
division and the live cell assay those
were some special cells and expressing
crumble bodies in the nucleus and I
can't say that I know a lot about them
but i'm sure you can put them up on the
web chroma body can you do these assays
on 60 right um yes there is no reason
you cannot the i'll give you the caveat
that it's weird we're doing most of our
work by hand and it's pretty difficult
to fix the steroids and have them stay
in the center of the bottom of the well
but yes there's no reason you can't if
the dyes are fixable that you could
image diff experience and the other
thing i think they ask you this one
earlier but let's let's just go again is
the MIT express software compatible with
any other platforms yes it is i it's
it's available to open any type of tiff
format or many other commonly use image
formats used by other microscope vendors
okay we'll pause for just a moment here
to see if we have time for another
question or two okay so we go how do you
remove the backgrounds in the picture in
order to quanta
by the fluorescence all right so you
don't necessarily have to remove the
background as long as what you are
trying to measure is higher than the
background and our software algorithms
the medic sprouts do a really great job
of picking out signal that is you know
very with the low threshold of intensity
and then of course with if you collect
your images with confocal the background
anyway will be reduced any background
fluorescence that's above and below the
plane that you're collecting and more
questions are coming in so just give us
the moment your cue to thread them
through this distance
how long does it take to analyze a
384-well plate so the time it takes to
analyze the plate will depend on the
complexity of the analysis desired but
we're also able to use some so it
depends on if you're doing a simple
count nuclei or if you're doing a multi
if you're analyzing a multiplexed assays
so it definitely can desire or can vary
we do have an option for implementing
parallel processing and multi-threading
of analysis which can speed up your
analysis to keep up with the acquisition
so for example if your plate took 15 to
20 minutes to acquire you could also
analyze that plate within the same time
frame by implementing multithreading
really will you be showing this system
at the flas meeting in there may be
showing the system at the SLA s meeting
in January or the HD a meeting in
February and where we have user group
meetings at these conferences we'll
definitely be showing the instrument at
those two meetings we will not have a
user group meeting at sls and i'm not
positive about HDA I'm sorry I'm you'll
have to watch our website as post is 40
x + 60 X oil as in the slides or 60 x +
100 x oil as just mentioned in most of
the slides I showed you the powerpoint
slides I guess you're talking about the
weird I use their objectives in all of
those in 40 X and my 60 X images if I
had some and then but you and which is
what's compatible with high high
throughput and if you want to use oil
objectives you certainly can and we and
like we said before we do sell some of
those objectives
ok so we're pause for just a moment
question for perhaps we will wrap just
give us a second here to see if we have
time to take another question or two I
would I I think we will stop here I i
would like to once again thank Jane be
Pat and Grisha for their presentations
do you have any final comments for you
paden um no I guess if there are any
more questions that we didn't get to I
see a couple that we've been giving some
thought to we can answer these people
individually there's no problem with
that defect is you have any closing
thoughts no we're just really excited
about the new platform and hoping that
everyone has a chance to ask and get
some get the information that they would
need out of it to see how it would help
with their you know their projects and
if they have any further questions your
local sales rep any of your application
scientists or you can direct them again
through the marketing team through our
website for any inquiries as well too
also just for current users you know we
have a lot of for current users who are
interested you can contact us and then
there's a lot of we have a lot of
resources available on our website you
know for finding out more information
such as our user forum as well for our
software users right and I know we've
we've started to wrap up but can I
despair one more question at you and it
is from what do you do if the
fluorescence from the background is high
and the fluorescence of the signal is
low so this is something typically that
we would approach a question either for
if your current user a tech support or
application science which would work
with you on you know there's only so
much that you can do with acquiring
the you know there's only so much that
you can do with you know using the
instrument and we might try to suggest
or you know work with you on going back
to the experimental procedure and see if
there's anything that might be optimized
there you know I'm sure that most of our
users have done a lot of athlete
evelopment but there might be some
tricks or tips that we've done in the
past to be able to boost that
additionally outside of the experimental
and what we can do on the hardware side
you know there's also maybe some things
that there are a lot of tools in meta
express that we could use to be able to
pull out some of that signal even if it
is low so there are a lot of tools
available in met Express to be able to
do that one good example would be our
homogeneous assays so if you would go to
our website and look up either our
posters or application out there be some
there might be some tips even if you're
not doing those exact assays you know we
might be able to provide some tips and
then if you are if this is a question
that you need further information on
please feel free to contact us the door
directly and maybe we might be able to
help thank you oh thank you thanks again
to our speakers as well as our sponsor
and molecular devices for making it
possible to bring this presentation to
you I'd also like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions and as Jane said
questions we did not have time for today
will be dressed by the speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through April 2016 you will receive an
email from us loading you when it's
available on demand and posted on lab
roots comms you're welcome to forward
this announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast see you next time